il est temps de mettre fin à cette
présidence du mépris et oui une autre
présidence est possible une présidente à
l'ecoute une présidence du respect une
présidence qui s'ancre dans les
territoires une présidence qui fait
confiance au maire qui fait confiance au
département qui fait confiance aux corps
intermédiaires qui fait confiance aux
associations qui fait confiance à ceux
qui entreprennent qui fait confiance
aussi aux français est-ce que emmanuel
macron a tout fait mal au cours des cinq
ans qui viennent de s'écouler sûrement
pas est ce qu'il a réussi des choses
bien sûr est-ce que nous sommes dans une
critique absolue cela n'a pas de sens
mais en revanche s'il ya un constat que
nous devons partager il n'a pas redressé
la france il n'a pas arrêté cette courbe
ou petit à petit quand on se lève on se
dit mais comment pouvons-nous faire
preuve d'autant de folie et laisser
notre pays de façon aussi systématique
prendre des directions qui nous semblent
l' inverse de ce qu il faudrait regarder
ce qui se passe avec le déficit
commercial
notre pays qui était terre d'agriculture
porté depuis henri iv qui maintenant en
est réduit à importer des produits
agricoles pour nourrir ses enfants
notre pays qui était une fierté qui
était écoutée respectée dans le concert
des nations humilié par l'australie et
les états unis et qui est en train
d'accumuler le pire déficit commercial
de la zone européenne notre pays dans
lequel tous chacun tels que nous sommes
dans la gestion de notre famille nous
nous employons à laisser à nos enfants
un héritage dans lequel le président de
la république pour des raisons purement
électorales qui n'ont rien à voir avec
la gestion de la crise du coc bible est
un train d'accumuler des dettes et des
déficits massifs qu'il faudra des
générations pour rembourser notre pays
enfin pierre ou dans nos grandes villes
nous voyons l'insécurité s'installer de
façon rampante avec des policiers des
gendarmes qui parce qu'ils ne sont plus
soutenues autrement que par des discours
creux et vide n'arrive plus à tenir la
sécurité notre pays enfin dans lequel
l'immigration est devenue totalement
incontrôlée par rapport à une époque
brice que nous avons connus où il y
avait quand même une autre fermeté et
bien tout ceci si nous faisons ce petit
pas de retrait si nous laissons de côté
partis les uns aux autres nos
orientations ne pouvons que constater
que rien de ceci n'a été améliorée ou
corriger en cinq ans nous avons une
chance historique
d'avoir une femme à la tête de notre
pays à la tête de notre pays mes amis
et tournon et tournons la page d'un
président macron s'enracine et sans
résultat
valérie tu as un programme clair
ambitieux fort avec des actes forts que
tu va développer partout en france
tu as le courage de dire dans quel état
et notre pays et tu as la volonté de fer
il faut le dire de faire les réformes
que mérite ce pays je crois qu'on peut
l'applaudir et le dire merci pour le
programme qu'elle veut mettre en place
pour relever notre pays
est le triptyque que nous utilisons
protéger éduquer soigner
répond parfaitement aux attentes des
français et de nos citoyens et je sais
valérie ici ça nous tient à coeur tu as
un fort volet sur l'agriculture et sur
la ruralité qui a été tant oublié je
sais que chaque fois que tu mettras un
euro en ville tu mettras un euro sur
cette belle ruralité qui en a bien
besoin je crois qu'on peut l'applaudir
là aussi on a été longtemps oubliée
heureusement qu'on a eu la région qui
nous a aidés qui nous a fortement aidé
sinon nous le département sinon nous
n'avions rien alors tout simplement
parce que j'ai deux minutes mes amis en
avril prochain soyons mobilisés allons
voir nos amis nos familles nos voisins
pour faire gagner la france pour qu'une
femme soit la présidente de la
république j'ai nommé valérie pécresse
notre pays a besoin de détermination et
de clarté sur quelques sujets ces sujets
il y en a deux dans notre pays à mes
yeux le et c'est le travail tu es ici
valérie dans une terre qui a été
construite par le travail tu es dans une
région qui croient à l'économie et à
ceux qui créent de la valeur et de
l'emploi tu es dans un endroit où on a
le même respect pour un artisan un
agriculteur un ouvrier de chez michelin
que pour un chef d'entreprise parce que
la valeur commune c'est celle du travail
notre pays est en train de décrocher
totalement sur son rapport au travail
j'avais à l'époque lilly a quasiment
maintenant 10 ans était critiqué pour
avoir dénoncé les méfaits à venir de
l'assistanat nous y sommes aujourd'hui
ceux qui travaillent ne sont plus
encourager ceux qui restent chez eux ne
gagnent pas plus pas moins que s'ils
allaient travailler nous avons
systématiquement mis à bas le rapport au
travail
et valérie avec beaucoup de courage dans
son émission de bfm a commencé en faire
un de ses traits marquants nous sommes
cette grande famille de la droite et du
centre qui croient dans la
réhabilitation du travail et qui est là
pour défendre ces classes moyennes qui
trop souvent sont oubliés dans notre
pays le deuxième de gordien c'est celui
de l'autorité de l'état nous ne pouvons
pas avoir un pays qui d'un côté nous
assomme de normes et de règles
insupportable et qui de l'autre côté est
incapable de faire preuve d'autorité sur
les sujets régaliens qui sont pourtant
le premier devoir d'un état républicain
dans notre pays et cette autorité elle
doit être la même portée par nos
policiers par nos gendarmes relayés par
nos yeux et relayées au plus haut sommet
de l'état
valérie là dessus a toujours fait preuve
de clarté et je n'oublie pas son combat
notamment quand les islamistes du ccf
voulait autoriser le burqini dans les
bases de loisirs d'île de france et que
sans avoir la main qui tremble valérie 7
opposés je veux être la présidente de
tous les français et tu l'as dit laurent
nous allons faire le serment du puits le
serment du puy en velay c'est que
désormais quand il y aura un euro qui
sera dépensé pour la politique de la
ville et bien il y aura un euro qui sera
dépensé en investissement pour la
ruralité de france aujourd'hui c'est
moitié moins de moyens
on les deux politiques
et pourquoi nous allons le faire va nous
allons faire parce que tout simplement
le monde de l'après qu'ovide il va
s'écrire aussi ici dans les villes
moyennes les bourgs dans les villages où
tant de français ont envie de retrouver
une qualité de vie qu'ils n'ont plus
dans les grandes métropoles mais pour
qu'il retrouve cette qualité de vie eh
bien il faudra que la ruralité soit
prête que la ruralité puisse développer
des projets que la ruralité puisse
construire que la ruralité puisse créer
de l'emploi et ça veut dire qu'il faudra
tout remettre à plat parce que les
politiques qui consiste à faire de la
décroissance agricole les politiques qui
consistent à geler les terres à diminuer
les espaces constructibles et qui
empêche la ruralité d'être vivante et
bien ça ne peut pas être les politiques
d'avenir que nous soutiendrons donc on
reverra complètement notre vision de ces
territoires ruraux qui doivent être le
coeur battant le coeur vivant de la
france
je voudrais mes amis
finir
avec un auteur que j'aime beaucoup et
qui parle de aussi cette france à
laquelle je suis attaché charles péguy
qui disait rien et meurtriers comme la
lave tes est rien et humains comme la
fermeté emmanuel macron n'a pas été
ferme il a été brutal il n'a pas été
humain il a été mais présent je suis
convaincu que valérie au contraire peut
incarner pour ce poste de président de
la république
cet équilibre dont nous avons besoin à
la fois une personnalité qui sait où
elle vend qui sera défendre avec
autorité les thèmes qui nous sont
précieux mais qui est de l'autre côté a
aussi compris qu'une présidente de la
république a le devoir de rassembler
tous les français d'avoir la même
attention pour les habitants des grandes
métropoles que pour nos territoires
ruraux d' arrêter d'opposer les uns aux
autres 7 francs soit disant qu'ils
gagnent les autres que l'on veux
emmerder d'un côté cette france de la
start up nation les autres que l'on
abandonne non la france ne repose pas là
dessus la france doit reposer sur une
union et sur un rassemblement là où nous
avons eu un président de la république
qui était brutal et mais présent
j'aspire à ce que nous ayons une
présidente de la république qui soit à
la fois ferme et humaine que ce soit ici
le serment du puy en velay que 2022
sonne l'heure du retour de la france